let's say you give what you want right  let's say that you start this company  you didn't do that self work right and  it works right now you're building this  company for 15 to 25 years because it's  making you a ton of money yeah you're  doing something you hate and now you're  just trapped in your own thing you  created right and you know there's  reasons to figure out why you just  literally take the step back in the  beginning and figure out if this is  right for you and why you should be  doing this yeah I can't even begin to  imagine what the boulder being like  super massive and then you're like at  the at the early a good way up the  mountain and it's so massive Boulder and  you're just sitting there holding it  going why did I bring this Boulder up  this is so bad  it's so much better to know every single  step along the way why you're doing this  why you're passionate about it  for example with